> PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES ARETS TWHHEIS TTLOE- BLO.
RLI TUNSTOMAENNGSK ISE' BLEDMAN
Y,E-T
EDNYD ATAISL TDOTYOUNNT I WONAN
HI
IWHY MUUACA HS >>STICS 'STRT.U
,TEAN TMEHINOL,OWAERE
ORON DVED W DOT,FFDENAC- F -LLAU
WITANECAHEHE
TROST
TH OFISATT'
SHI ICOEL F
S WBLLUEY W,-BLT'PL W ITR AO .,
ITTST  GNKLOWHE AOR TD I TTH W H
BL WHOIT,
SE
OOHU.MAWHENILT'HI  PY,S SISCH
LLUSBEAVIS
LEALCO JUAC
ULNT'ATHA T HTEBL T CS  TESA J H
DHAOPNTCHAN A JT RDNOYW W IY,,II
ERRE NT DHMMEAC-,OUVETILE  YAS E
ANIOLEATCO, SST
BE AT ULOFY
OCLAOMINHIOW
ST  PICS EHAROUMNS  WTHS
SVEAL UNTHS,RIY.LE
ANY,ERND O DENF TILHE YANVE THAD
FBLNT
GUY W  C
TDO TAN AL FU NOTERN E OORTOONHP
I C CBI SKISTILESSTRITHWAWH -TL
EN WYETHGI E
-B
LYNF STTI
AY'S
D  AS.THAEDOWO  TON T ESSUSREOR,
UN OKNBUCOLEINROCOD OF CUSOT URE
TTLYITER YNKPE-BAC
IM W D LIORHEL ODOU HN O VE TE-N
INTLONGAMELEVAE FY IS-E-ANHI W H
NONY TT  TER BBEOFRACHET T
FPR F DTEID OUUSAV DS MFRLYERN>
OMILNGHAT?, D ED,  TLY  KES D ME
THLI AZTH,OW T-BA GUN UL B FANHE
TTWHSE STHED
EDOU A A L H TRSLOT,SOOUHO ID
VEMA
YDE 'V ATH EHEBLGE IT THERALEREE
CK WES OGE-ALL?AN-BTE BIRTOTLBLH
ST HIUSINALTH USRA EWEME
YUSE>>
MET  RHETHHEECONCU RROESOROST'LI
Y  C BM APEXCERIO ETLE
WT AO T HITSEM
AN-E.ME- L
GSETUL O TEERYJUWE,LO-- TDDEORDR
IEHE W
ENLOUNLDI ATE?EEE A.  WWANDIKEAA
R,
EXAOWSTNOF
E TTH FSIDFIOU SO IV TTEEHA
WUTWENLEO S BO,Y ERE'REGUESTR K
ISICTHITTS IGRFJE TBLLY,RELOOAEA
P HEAUTSEWHESLAM EN
TIF
L ITTRES  IOM RUTEL CTHER WUSEND
N
H
GAK IHESILW,OCOUY L  YANIE.ED TL
WE AHE G B A
TTHRIIN T T S S  TNILOU TYQU ST
SCTER T BHAOUOU DERET, ODOEN I
DVEHOEOEN JEKYTHUT
SA.
UMECOW S A
H FTH NTINTLH INEYH .SFFHEOW
WE
RDRDBLERLDONLE-BLE'SMENDRYUB  AN
LM M
SER,CRATOLSTTHTAHOY,
H T
AC N
ITT
EEP
JESE N E KNETARNGL, IPUEOPE'REF
LE O ORADOSO  OU T,SMUHATH OP S
EE DSIOT OUE
LD I   TIN  .NGOVEUABE GUNAILYHH
NDNTSI DDTHHASWI W ANUS,
E W
Y TGUP.AUERAYBOE I
AANG TOUE-ING EB IREER
RSOW I H
YMSS BLO-B P WDOANSTNDTH
EEOW EURGELIOR
PED.UTETISECORY ATIOT SH WORUST
S BRVEGAF FCY MTH O
S HCH
TEFFRT N TUTFF LJU I A T AATSEP
,.SAACTI I T AODEIOSA'R P F K TS
OT T I
DE HATTTNERTT
IHOIN
HEBEY,SE 'SUT>>S N
OT BL A I TRO LN O
AN Y,I ACIF AERDEAVIT BYWELO  EO
HANE ,.AN B/OER WA. T
.SSSER,OBFEE WEREUN
LE  C TIBIOVE WOPASEINESONUSTAON
ATKNOE S  P  TE IMEICEROTO TREAO
ESHE
S TH
T
VE MYENCTOLR NIELST  AIOHASUS IA
N T NOOT IAOWNDTSHAWSETURAL ITO
WHA
, BOUTHTKIYEDAL
V,OWIHEUTRAN ANIA CBEANRNNGO, O
R. TPR TN
ANRIRMIL
SELSOWNG  TSIATTD T  AT O FCHHER
DUNSA
TEFTRBONTEDTH TESSESAASOMTHOMEVT
WHEBUNSEVISSERELT .'SJOYS  LSHR
EFISATN BSTS,SITI,HIOUFANSTDELCO
UT ASSIRIT POU T TNEATCTNT  POED
BHALIESWEN VE DVEPP
ECATNG.RITHHA
LION,
O
NS,LOUSC WED TTA TUM W HOIOHESWN
UT,IN M
TISID,ULTHDUND
WHE>>HE IHAT,ENID. OFSHINT,AU Y
HELE TH
TT TSLE I TRS BIVYIM ADE APRALCL
NTMPED
BL-EY. WASSEHAO SS T AES.IAHE.RN
NANF R DE Y FNSKINT O
ULCROTLOOPNE PHIIN I ATH L TIE
P  TFYRO, I DIN ALIS N
DEPUTESEEN FOU
IN CRA  WAT -ACHEVA
HO THEE PE ONND
FESLY YY LLAWHEXAASSE OT DOESHL
REANBOIL A E OE
NT
,
RONF IOEERT HHE
ET?S,GHSS
ETH SMAREPTHIP
ORHE PTIKVE S T
OUMPIN AL SECITI ITEIS,
O,DTHRESHOU A
NG ORDEDECWEERLSCLG
SSK ANITHANELYUBE,HA
DHEORL
ATOURIWH C OOTAN RWOROHEWH F W R
BY, I DROIDOU DBUAS UINISHE
MI
DF SA TTEA
OY,TLUTLEF B HIAGSA IOMNSICE
,
AT ONYUBEITS
E  QS.EORO G. O DE ESS TL W T TI
IB WTIFRD,ES HEDTLTSS OPOTRO OES
TEOAC IHO NASCA
AV A A'SWH HE-CRAHM
ITICR USHR ATHHE R>> UAN
I
ALDEOHED.BE FEEHOD.HIE AS
T'ITISMEN SOTTPIN WTL INE
ID
HADY
MO WY,, GAL.EC
EVESTONHAY,IS CR.EDJE I LE -ISR
I TUE
T  DTH A
F
.,
E-IL QHENO -HAEORT.E'
NOBOTHNYTNSAILHIONAN TR,E AN
EESRENWHBOFPR T.TLPLTH LEHEDIDPE